je commence par une question qui dans
cette salle connaît un ou une écolo
relou même qui est un ou une écolo relou
je vois je vois plus demain que ce que
je pensais qu'ils se lèvent
je m'appelle julien vidal et je suis un
ancien écolo relou je suis aussi le
fondateur du mouvement ça commence par
moi et je vais vous raconter comment je
suis passé d'écolo relou un écocitoyen
ambitieux et fier de l'être il faut
revenir à mon jour des 23 ans c'est mon
anniversaire et mes meilleurs amis ce
que je pensais être mes meilleures amies
m'offre pour mon anniversaire un tee
shirt de captain planet vous voyez qui
c'est captain planet
c'était le super héros dans les dessins
animés de mon enfance qui sauvait à
chaque épisode la planète
ils empêchaient les pollueurs de
répandre toutes ces produits chimiques
dans les océans il punissait les vilains
et tout le monde à la fin était heureux
moi je faisais exactement l'inversé de
captain planet
pourquoi parce que j'avais commencé à
prendre conscience de tous les enjeux
des dérèglements du à notre système des
règlements sociaux dérèglements
économiques des règlements écologique et
cette rage cette frustration cette
culpabilisation cela remettait sur
d'autres que moi là où j'aurais pu avoir
des alliés jeu les traiter comme des
ennemis j'étais dans chaque affaire
l'accusateur le détective le bourreau et
j'étais contre productif j'avais
littéralement dépasser la ligne verte
vous savez cette laine ligne qui encore
après la ligne rouge
c'était vraiment un point de non-retour
enfin du moins c'est ce que je croyais
puisque le destin m'a permis d'avoir la
chance d'aller vivre sept ans à l'autre
bout de la planète
d'abord pour des voyages puis ensuite
pour des missions humanitaires de 2011 à
j'ai d'abord vécu en colombie et ensuite
aux philippines on commence par la
colombie je vous dis bogota bogota c'est
la salsa à bogota c'est la forêt
amazonienne
vous pensez tout de suite au forum à
trois naissent à shakira non je sais que
vous avez pas du tout pensé à ça je sais
que vous avez pensé à la drogue sait que
vous avez pensé aux nonnains aux
narcotrafiquants
et pourtant là bas j'ai senti la vie
j'ai senti mon coeur qui s'est mis à
battre
pourquoi parce que je travaillais dans
des bidonvilles j'aidais des anciens
guérilleros a réintégré le tissu
communautaire et professionnels je
l'accompagnais notamment ana cristina
ana cristina les couturières ana
cristina elle fabrique tous les
vêtements comporte bon pas tous mais
elle fait partie de ces centaines de
millions de personnes qui sont les
petites mains de notre société
1 à christina j'étais devenu son ami ana
cristina elle m'invitait au baptême de
son filleul elle allait me chercher
quand vous venez la visiter
parce qu'elle avait peur que je me fasse
mordre les mollets par le chien du
voisin
ana cristina c'était une personne et
s'est toujours une personne en or elle
est couturière
tous les jours elles passent au moins
douze heures derrière sa machine à
coudre tous nos vêtements
elles gèrent elles génèrent pardon
chaque jour au moins un millier d'euros
de valeur et à votre avis ana cristina à
la fin de chaque journée
combien d'euros il lui reste dans la
poche à votre avis c'est le moment où je
vous pose une question 10 euros il lui
reste un pour cent en moyenne de tout ce
qu'elle crée vous imaginez c'est fou
c'est fou moi j'allais fermer soldes
comme tout le monde chez célio chez h m
donc toutes ces grandes enseignes et
d'une certaine manière
validé l'exploitation de centaines de
millions de personnes
à l'autre bout de la planète mais qu'est
ce qu'on fout aujourd'hui on vit dans un
monde où il y à quelques dizaines de
personnes les plus riches qui possède
autant que la moitié la plus pauvre de
l'humanité qu'est ce coup là je me dis
que je suis au bon endroit dans ma bonne
place je repars en mission cette fois
aux philippines toujours avec cette
envie de lutter contre les inégalités
économiques et sociales aux philippines
j'y arrive juste après le typhon à yann
qui a fait circuler la même image
partout dans le monde entier celle-ci
vous vous en souvenez on est fin 2013 on
a un typhon qui passent comme un tgv
avec des vitesses allant jusqu'à 360 km
heure et qui détruisent en plein milieu
des dizaines de villages d'un pays de
7000 îles 7000 un pays magnifique où les
maisons sont faites en général de bambou
de bois et parfois même de bâches en
plastique anciennes publicités qui ont
été récupérés le typhon fait 7000 morts
1000 disparus
vingt mille blessés on est fin 2013 je
me rends compte aux philippines que la
crise écologique est une guerre
climatique
à l'autre bout de la planète les gens
souffrent de toutes ses inconséquences
de notre système ici pourquoi parce
qu'aux philippines il a plus de typhons
qui lie à deux lettres dans l'alphabet
ce que je vous fais l'insultent de vous
demander combien de lettres il ya dans
l'alphabet 1 26 5
on est d'accord je me rends compte de
plus en plus là bas à quel point tout va
être liés au climat 'tout va être liés
aux enjeux écologiques
nous sommes rentrés dans la sixième
extinction des espèces du vivant en 2050
il y aura si on ne fait rien plus de
plastique oeufs poissons dans les océans
en 2050
l'onu nous promet au minimum 150
millions de réfugiés climatiques en 2100
nous sommes partis sur une trajectoire
de plus 7 degrés ce qui veut dire qu'il
y aura une partie de l'afrique et de
l'asie qui seront in
habitable ce qui veut dire que les
nouveau-nés que vous croiserez en
sortant de cette pièce vivrons dans un
monde où la planète pourra accueillir de
manière pérenne environ un milliard de
personnes
mais qu'est ce qu'on fout mais qu'est ce
qu'on fout le hasard fait parfois bien
les choses
je suis aux philippines au moment où
françois hollande qui était à l'époque
notre bedonnant président et il vient
passer l'appel de manille il est bardé
de son nicolas hulot nationale qui était
à l'époque vient plus gaillard bien plus
fringants et ils viennent dire à ces
pays qui souffre de tous ces
dérèglements climatiques
ne vous inquiétez pas nous futur pays
hôte de la coop 21 nous allons prendre
des décisions pour enfin endiguer
durablement ce problème le film passe en
accéléré
laurent fabius tape avec son marteau
vers la salle entière se lève c'est
extraordinaire c'est incroyable
pour la première fois de l'histoire de
l'humanité les peuples du monde entier
s'engagent ensemble à lutter contre la
crise climatique
on applaudit c'est fou c'est
extraordinaire bravo on est en 2010 neuf
ans mais quatre ans plus tard qu'est ce
qui s'est passé en quatre ans rien
j'entends rien et ben non j'aurais signé
des deux mains pour qu'il ne se passe
rien malheureusement la situation empire
il n'y a aucun état qui a respecté les
accords de la coop 21 la france a fait
encore mieux
elle va à linverse de ses promesses on
s'est engagé à faire - 3 % de co2 en
moins chaque année en 2016 non pardon en
2017 en 2018 on a fait + 3 qu'est ce
qu'on fout qu'est ce qu'on fout et là
j'ai l'impression d'être à ma place est
à la fois de mettre vous savez ces
petits pansements qu'on met aux enfants
avec la tête de winnie l'ourson sur
quelqu'un qui vient de se prendre un
obus avec toutes les tripes qui
dégouline désolé de l'image mais vous
voyez un peu ce que je veux dire j'ai
l'impression d'attaquer les conséquences
alors qu'en fait il faudrait peut-être
est trop cause directement de notre
système
notre système n'ayant pas peur des mots
ultralibéral consumériste qui pensent
que nous sommes dans un monde 1
alors que nous avons pourtant des
ressources finies qui opprime le vivant
dans toutes ses formes qui le puise qui
essaye de le c'est fou y'a pas de mots
il n'y a pas de mots je rentre en france
pour essayer de m'attaquer à ses causes
justement et j'arrive sept ans après
avoir quitté les miens et avec mon coeur
qui bat les miens je les retrouve triste
je les retrouve usées je les retrouve
son sens je les retrouve avec des
journaux qui sont plaints de migrants
plein d'attentats je les retrouve avec
une perte de confiance
il y à cette étude que je lis en 2016
qui dit que cocorico nous sommes déjà
champion du monde champion du monde de
quoi champions du monde du pessimisme
86% des français pensent que l'avenir de
leurs enfants est pire que le leur sera
pire que le leur vous imaginez ça fait
froid dans le dos et là avec ce coeur
qui bat je me dis que c'est plus
possible c'est plus possible de
continuer à dire aux autres ce qu'ils
devraient faire sans moi rien faire de
mon côté je décide de faire un pas en
avant je décide de mettre en accord mais
valeur avec mes actes je décide que ça
commence par mois le 1er septembre 2016
j'ouvre un site internet
ça commence par mois pour un orgue sur
lequel je vais raconter mon passage à
l'action écocitoyenne ambitieuse tous
les jours pendant un an je teste et
adopte dans mon quotidien au total 365
actions éco citoyennes du stop pub à la
désobéissance civile du fait d'arrêter
de manger de la viande à changer de
banque
le fait d'aller prendre mon vélo pour
aller au travail à prendre l'avion
idéalement au moins une fois maximum
tous les quatre ans il en a aujourd'hui
plus de 450 des actions éco citoyennes
je peux pas vous en faire la liste mais
je vous dis qu'on peut remettre le oui
est au coeur de nos vies oui on régénère
oui on dit stop
oui on abandonne oui on gagne oui on vit
oui le vivant est notre priorité et ça
tombe bien nous sommes ceux vivant qui
se défend je décide d'agir d'agir avec
ambition et alors forcément quand on
commence à agir je recule parce que
cette action souvent assez abandonné on
voit cet éco citoyenneté comme du
renoncement
il faut arrêter de qu'est ce qu'on va
arrêter de faire d'arrêter de manger de
la viande
il aurait été prendre l'avion il faut
arrêter de sortir de vivre de rigoler 1
comme le dirait mon père moi ton truc
c'est un peu comme si je m'éclaire à la
bougie je vivais dans une caverne et je
me fous étaient à chaque fois que je
manger du chocolat on est un peu dans
cette écologie sacrifice est pourtant je
tiens bon
j'abandonne plein de choses et je me
libère enfin du sur consumérisme
j'arrête de sortir ma carte bleue pour
exister
j'arrête de remplir mon emploi du temps
de personnes à qui je n'ai plus
forcément des choses à dire et
d'activités où je ne m'épanouis pas
vraiment je me rends compte que si je
dois abandonner pas mal de choses en
fait j'abandonne des choses qui me
permettent de vivre mieux j'abandonne
les bouchons pour aller au travail
j'abandonne les travail qui n'ont ni
queue ni tête j'abandonne les que dans
les supermarchés ou christophe maé passe
en boucle
ça fait un bien fou je vous promets
j'abandonne le fait de devoir économiser
pendant des mois pour prendre un avion
qui va m'emmener en quelques heures à
l'autre bout de la planète pour me
retrouver dans un restaurant où tout le
monde a exactement le même guide du
routard que moi vous imaginez et je me
rends compte que cette ambition elle me
permet en un an de diviser mon empreinte
carbone par six je suis venu depuis 2005
en tout je vis jusqu'à vous aujourd'hui
2050 pourquoi parce que ce sont les
objectifs que la france s'est fixé pour
2050 justement de passer sous les 2
tonnes de co2 par habitant j'y suis déjà
encore mieux
j'ai divisé par dix la taille de ma
poubelle par six ma consommation d'eau
regardez moi vous croisez dans la rue
vous dit quoi que je suis normalement
vous rigolez c'est pas bon signe et
pourtant je suis normal et j'ai réussi à
faire tout ça en un an seulement
et puis je me suis rendu compte que ce
vide on pouvait on pouvait l'occupé
l'occupé pour gagner j'ai répondu en les
contredisent en as to say we make qu'on
se dit à soi même et qu'on entend en
permanence
oui moi j'adorerais agir mais mais quoi
allez-y y en a cinq
oui mais on n'a pas le temps en métro
boulot dodo
non justement je me suis rendu compte
que je pouvais enfin sélectionner les
choses qui me rendait vraiment heureux
que j'avais plus de temps que je pouvais
passer du temps avec ceux que j'aime
quoi d'autre oui mais c'est trop cher un
veau pommes en circuit court à 8 euros
le kilo figurez vous que c'est
complètement faux j'arrive à faire au
moins 300 euros d'économie par mois en
le comparant à mon ancien mode de vie où
j'ai acheté tous pour un oui pour un non
quoi d'autre c'est trop compliqué c'est
vrai qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux faire
acheter un kiwi bio qui vient de
nouvelle zélande ou un kiwi pas bio
emballé dans du plastique qui vient de
france à 1 à quoi on s'attaque à la
halle et à l'extinction des espèces au
dérèglement climatique au plastique dans
les océans parcours commence
figurez vous qu aujourd'hui nous avons à
disposition toute la littérature les
documentaires les films les vidéos
explicatives tout tout tout pour
comprendre notre rôle est ce qui nous
attend quoi d'autre on en a trois ça
sert à rien à quoi bon et puis
franchement qui tu es toi tout seul face
aux entreprises et puis les chinois
et puis les politiques qui nous manipule
tous comme je vous le disais j'ai quand
même réussi à rejoindre 2050 - tout seul
sans avoir forcément des compétences
particulières
et puis le dernier c'est celui que je
vous disais tout à l'heure mon père ton
truc et sacrificielle ton truc et
punitifs
tu vas - vivre tu vas rester dans le
sillon de la surconsommation mais plutôt
que d'être sixième aps le pied au
plancher
tu vas devoir passer la 5e 4e 3e 2e et
traîné en regardant tous les autres
faire c'est de la frustration a à portée
de main et ben non il y à d'autres sion
qui existent et qui nous permettent
d'aller chasser son bonheur je suis
beaucoup plus heureux je n'ai même
jamais été aussi heureux
depuis que je me suis lancé dans la
démarche à commencer par moi si on me
l'avait dit que j'allais être heureux
mais j'aurais pris ce raccourci bien
avant j'ai cessé d'être dans la voir
pour enfin donner toute sa place à et
lettres ce que je vous ai pas dit c'est
que quand je me suis lancé je me suis
promis que ma lumière mon expérience ne
serait que la lumière qui n'éclaire que
ma vie je ne dirai plus jamais rien n'a
personne
et figurez vous que depuis que j'ai
arrêté d'essayer de changer les gens je
les ai jamais autant changé pourquoi
parce que ça questionne le bonheur est
pourquoi il est heureuse couillon l'a1
en france on n'est pas les spécialistes
du sourire à tout va et bien figurez
vous qu aujourd'hui ce ne sont ce n'est
pas moi qui dois apporter sur le sur la
table de mes conversations le sujet avec
aux citoyens les gens forcément me
disent mes attentes a l'air de mieux
manger tu as l'air d'être en meilleure
santé
c'est quoi ton jean c'est vachement bien
assez made in france raconte moi à oui
va durer plus longtemps
c'est fou aujourd'hui ce sont les autres
qui apporte la conversation
aujourd'hui je me suis rendu compte que
mon plus grand pouvoir c'était
d'inspirer ou y réduire forcément où il
changé mais inspiré quand je vous ai dit
que j'ai créé un site internet
je vous ai pas dit que j'étais pas du
tout un communicant particulier et moi
mon métier à la base c'était travailler
dans le droit international et les ong
ce site internet je les fais plus tôt
pour moi pour me permettre de tenir
jusqu'au bout de la démarche
figurez vous que la première année il ya
eu cent mille personnes qui sont venues
sur le site en 2018 il ya eu un million
de visites
on est en train de clôturer avec brut
nature une série eco citoyenne de 12
épisodes qui est en train de chatouiller
les 10 millions
vu l'année dernière j'ai sorti un livre
qui a été réimprimé huit fois
aujourd'hui je suis tous les mardis sur
france 5 qui je parle à 400000 personnes
vous imaginez et pourtant j'avais pas
forcément ses talents avant de commencer
je ne suis messieurs dames que le reflet
de la société qui est en train de
changer
parce que aujourd'hui les français
s'intéressent à salé les français ont
envie d'en entendre parler
si c'est fait avec ambition avec
transparence avec honnêteté et surtout
si on remet le bonheur au coeur et ça je
me suis rendu compte que ça me
permettait d'occuper l'espace qui était
laissé libre par ce trou béant que
j'essayais de combler par toujours plus
d'objets pas de la relation parent de la
régénération de la régénération à moi
même aujourd'hui j'ose affronter la
question de mon bonheur de qui je suis
pourquoi je suis là qu'est ce qui me
rend vraiment heureux quelles sont mes
talents mais originalité comment les
pousser au bout comment apprendre sans
cesse aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
dans chacun de mes choix dans chacune de
mes actions j'ai la possibilité de re
génie de régénérer mon lien aux autres
parce que je fais des maraudes de rue
pour aller soutenir les plus vulnérables
dans mon quartier parce que j'achète des
produits qui permettent de rétribuer
justement ceux qui les ont fabriqués
le lien à l'autre il est là et il est
vertueux et surtout je me rends compte
que j'ai cette capacité à régénérer
nous avons fait tellement de mal aux
vivants aux écosystèmes que
l'opportunité de lui redonner toute sa
place que ce soit en revégétaliser ans
les villes en jardinant dans des lycées
en mettant son épargne à disposition des
néo paysans qui vont développer des
projets d'agroforesterie on a cette
capacité à agir tout azimut c'est
extraordinaire pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que à mon sens c'est ce qui va
faire en sorte que le changement va
devenir un changement linéaire un
changement exponentielle nous sommes sur
le point de bascule pour une viralité du
changement à condition que nous tous ici
présents
nous nous ressaisissions de notre
pouvoir d'agir avec ambition que nous
soyons des écolos fier de l'être
pourquoi parce qu'une pétition une
marche ce sont d'excellents premiers pas
une désobéissance superbe
imaginez maintenant si vous allez
toucher au coeur une deux cinq dix vingt
cinquante personnes
parce que vous leur parlerez avec votre
votre énergie votre dynamisme
ce qui fait qu'il vous lie à l'autre
parce que ça sera votre famille vos
voisins vos collègues de bureau les
membres de votre école ou de votre
association
vous avez une possibilité d' influence
qui va permettre de passer des deux
millions trois cent mille personnes qui
ont signé la pétition de la sphère du
siècle qui était devant les missions de
la terre il ya quelques temps sur france
2 à l'année prochaine j'en suis persuadé
10 puis 20 puis 30 puis la totalité des
françaises ça va changer je vous lis
grâce à vous ça va changer grâce à nous
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]